las consecuencias de la crisis política
boliviana de 2019 siguen muy presentes
defensores de derechos humanos y
familiares de las víctimas de las
masacres les acaba en cochabamba y se
encarta en el alto en cercanías de la
paz se manifestaron ante la fiscalía y
los tribunales de justicia una veintena
de civiles perdieron la vida en
enfrentamientos con el ejército y la
policía días después de que jeanine áñez
asumiera la presidencia del país tras la
renuncia de evo morales
no es un año y nueve meses en donde sólo
tenemos cuatro cautelados el general
valverde el general flórez el general
hierro y el general inchauste todos a
los militares exigen que los
colaboradores de la ex presidenta
interina
principalmente el ex presidente carlos
mesa el gobernador de santa cruz luis
fernando camacho el ex alcalde de la paz
luis revilla sean también incorporados
al proceso judicial que se encuentra hoy
encarcelada en la paz bajo acusaciones
de terrorismo sedición y conspiración
el viernes manifestantes se realizaron
una vigilia en cochabamba exigiendo
justicia para la ex presidenta interina
que intentó suicidarse el mes pasado en
prisión según su abogado
a su juicio de responsabilidades contra
yanine sí
pero primero debe de ser juzgado en un
juicio de responsabilidades para que
allí sea sometida al juicio se necesita
la aprobación de dos tercios del
parlamento sus opositores aseguran que
si el proceso no se da acudir a las
instancias internacionales en busca de
justicia según datos de la defensoría
del pueblo 37 personas murieron en la
crisis de 2019 la gran mayoría de ellos
en sacaba y senkata